it's interesting to to think whether the
the the things that threaten us is the
stuff we see that's happening gradually
or the stuff we don't really see that's
going to happen all of a sudden and
sometimes like think about what is what
should we be more worried about because
it seems like like with the asteroids or
nuclear war it could be stuff that just
happens one day you know when I say one
day meaning over of a few days or a few
months but on a you know not on a scale
of decades and
centuries cuz we sometimes mostly talk
about stuff that's happening
gradually but we can be really
surprised it's actually really
interesting and that was actually one of
the reasons it took a while to determine
what it was that had caused the last
extinction because people did think at
the time many people thought that things
were more gradual and the idea of
Extinction was a very was actually a
novel concept at some point you know I
mean these aren't predictable events
necessarily they're only predictable on
a grand scale um but sometimes sometimes
they are and and I think people were
pretty aware that nuclear um weapons
were dangerous I'm not sure people are
as aware now as they were you know say
20 or 30 years ago and that certainly
worries me um I have to say I was not as
worried about AI as other people but
now I understand and it's not I mean
it's more that as soon as you create
things that we lose control over it's
scary and the other thing that we're
learning from the events today is that
is that it takes a few bad actors it
takes everyone to sort of make things
work well it takes not that many things
to make things go wrong it's it's the
issue with disease you know we can find
out what causes a disease but to make
things better is not necessarily that
simple sometimes it is but for things to
be healthy a lot of things have to work
for things to go wrong only one thing
has to go wrong and so it's amazing that
we do and the same is true for democracy
for democracy to work a lot of people
have to believe in it a few bad actors
can destroy things sometimes so a lot of
the things that we really rely on are
delicate equilibrium situ some of you
know and there is some robustness in the
systems we try to build in robustness
but a few extreme events can sometimes
alter things and um I think that's what
people are scared of today in many ways
they're scared of it for democracy
they're scared of it for peace they're
scared of it for AI I think they're not
as scared as they should be about
nuclear weapons to be honest um I think
that's a more serious danger Than People
realize um I think people are a little
bit more scared about pandemics than
they were before um but I still say
they're not super scared about it so
you're right there are these major
events that can happen and we are
setting things up so that they might
happen and we should be thinking about
them the question is who should be
thinking about them how should we be
thinking about them how do you make
things happen on a global scale because
that's really what we need it certainly
shouldn't be a source of division it
should be a source of grand
collaboration probably wouldn't that be
nice yeah I just wonder what it would be
like a to be a dinosaur it must have
been beautiful to like look at that
astronoid just enter the atmosphere
until like everything just
man would I that' be one of the things I
would travel back in time to you know
that's one of the things that I think
you probably could do with virtual
reality I don't think you have to be
there and get extin just experience it I
think there's something you know it's an
event you're just watching you're not
doing anything you're just looking at it
so maybe you could just recreate it I
actually heard that there a there's a
nuclear weapon explosion experience in
virtual reality that's good to remind
you
about like what it would feel like I
have to say you know so I got I got an
award from the Museum of nuclear history
and technology in the southwest and I
went to visit the museum which turned
out to be mostly a museum of nuclear
weapons and the scary thing is that they
look really cool you know it's true that
you have that yes this is scary but you
also have this this is cool feeling and
I think we have to get around that
because yeah I'm I kind of think that
yes you can be in that but not sure
that's going to make people scared has
it have they actually asked afterwards
are you more or less scared yeah that's
a good
uh it's a really good point I mean
that's a good summary of just Humanity
in general
we're attracted to creating cool stuff
even though it's can be dangerous and
actually that was the really interesting
thing about visiting that museum
actually it was very nice cuz I had a
tour from people who had been working
there on the Cold War and actually one
or two people from the Manhattan Project
it was a very very cool tour and you
just realize just how just the thing
itself gets you so excited I think
that's something that sometimes these
movies Miss just the thing itself you're
not thinking about the the overall
consequences and it was kind of like in
some ways it was like the early Silicon
Valley you know people were just
thinking like what if we did this what
if we did that and you know not keeping
track of like what the peripheral
consequences are and you definitely see
that happening with AI now I mean I
think that was the moral of the battle
that just happened that you know it's
just Full Speed Ahead which gives me a
really great transition to another quote
in your book so you you write about it
the experience of facing the sublime in
physics and you quote uh Ryan
ER quote for beauty is nothing but the
beginning of Terror which we are still
just able to endure and we're so odd
because it serenely disdains to
annihilate us it's pretty intense it I
think applies to nuclear weapons but it
also I mean at a more mundane perhaps
level I think it applies you know it's
really interesting one of the things I
found when I wrote these books is you
know some people love certainty you know
scientists kind of many Revel in
uncertainty it's not that you want to be
uncertain you want to solve it but
you're at this Edge where it's really
frustrating because you don't really
want to not know the answer but of
course if you knew the answer that would
be it would be done
so you're always at this Edge where
there's you're trying to sort things out
and there is something scary you don't
know what is you don't know if there's
going to be a solution you don't know if
you're going to find it so it's not
something that can destroy the Earth
it's just something that you do on your
individual level but then of course
there are much bigger things like the
ones you're talking about where they
could actually be dangerous the stuff I
do I just want to be clear I'm doing
theoretical physics not very dangerous
um but sometimes things end up having
bigger consequences than you think yeah
[Music]
but dangerous in a very pragmatic sense
but isn't it still in part terrifying
when you think of a just the size of
things like the size of dark matter like
the the power of this thing in terms of
uh his his potential gravitational
effects just this cosmological objects
of a black hole at the center of our
galaxy so this might be where why I'm a
physicist or why I differ from other
people yeah because I'm not such a big
fan of humanity in some ways some ways I
am but the idea that we were everything
would be really boring to me I love the
idea that there's so much more out there
that there's a bigger universe and
there's lots to discover and that we're
not all there is wouldn't it be
disappointing if we were all there is
yeah and uh the full diversity of other
stuff it's pretty interesting you know
we have no idea how much there is you
know we we know what we what we can
observe so far so the idea that there's
other stuff out there that we yet have
to figure out it's
exciting